on vient chez nous ça bouillonne fort
vous le savez à québec le ministre mars
on le voit et c'est des chaussures
neuves des chaussures aldo pendant
qu'une date se profile à l'horizon pour
d'éventuelles élections on parle du 14
avril ou du 7 avril en attendant
beaucoup de projets de loi qui
s'accumulent en attendant d'être adopté
martin biron
elles sont noires québécoise est
finalement plutôt classique ces
nouvelles chaussures a précisé le
ministre des finances porte un message
alors qu'il s'apprête à déposer son
deuxième budget sur les autres que c'est
un budget responsable et puis j'ai très
hâte à jeudi de vous le présenter
le devoir de la voix d'alex sur les
ennemis mais ce budget sera-t-il
accompagné du livre des dépenses y
aura-t-il des compressions dans les
services publics a demandé l'opposition
ce que je dis aux citoyens citoyennes du
québec nous n'augmenterons pas votre
fardeau fiscal la semaine s'annonce donc
chargé les sondages enivre les péquistes
qui commence à rêver d'en découdre
rapidement avec leurs adversaires il se
passe quelque chose au québec depuis
quelques mois selon nos informations
pauline marois ne veut pas tenir des
élections en mars
elle envisage plutôt un scrutin le 7 ou
le 14 avril si elle devait prendre cette
décision il ne resterait que deux jours
pour clore la session parlementaire bien
contexte que tout le monde connaît et on
est des projets de loi qui sont qui ont
eu beaucoup d'heures consacrées et de
temps il faudrait pas qui est ce qu'on
appelle meure au feuilleton le projet de
loi sur l'inspecteur général à montréal
sera remis le projet de loi sur le
nouveau code de procédure civile a des
chances d'être adoptée de celui sur
l'aide médicale à mourir que paraît en
danger ou hors de question que je l'aimé
ce droit de parole des députés du parti
libéral entre 30 et 40 députés libéraux
veulent s'exprimer le temps pourrait
manquer un débat sain et responsable se
nomme bibeau a un agenda électoral il
reste que tous se préparent à la joute
électorale mener la bataille de ma vie
pendant 35 jours pour convaincre les
québécois le délicat projet de loi sur
l'aide médicale à mourir a pourtant
l'appui des libéraux les parties
continuent de négocier pour tenter de
l'adopter d'ici jeudi mais malgré cinq
ans de travaux parlementaires le
compromis semble toujours difficile
ici martin biron radio canada québec
ont rejoint sébastien beauvais à québec
sébastien évidemment ceux qui l' élément
qui explique pourquoi les québécois
iront voter soit le 14 ou le 7 avril ce
sont les sondages et en a eu 1 ce matin
qui a fait plaisir aux péquistes sondage
crop publié dans la presse qui nous
apprend que pauline marois est
littéralement le vent dans les voiles
regardons les chiffres si vous le voulez
si des élections avaient eu lieu ces
jours-ci le parti québécois rire que des
40% des intentions de vote 47 % chez les
francophones ce qui lui aurait donné un
gouvernement majoritaire le plq et à 34%
la caq à 16% et vous voyez québec
solidaire et option nationale c'est un
gain de 5 points par rapport au dernier
sondage ce sont les indécis semble-t-il
qui vont vers le parti québécois mais
c'est fragile disent indécis par
définition des fois ça peut changer
d'avis ce que on me dit que les
stratèges du parti québécois regardent
surtout ce sont les prochains chiffres
qui ferait le meilleur premier ministre
pauline marois à 30% fils pris 1 22%
françois legault à 13 pour ça et
françoise david à 6% ce sont d'après les
gens qui j'ai parlé des chiffres peut
être un peu plus stable un peu plus
rigoureux si on veut que les intentions
de vote parce que c'est un sondage
vraiment exceptionnel aujourd'hui est
surprenant même et madame marois qui a
monté petit à petit dans cette cette
question là depuis des mois et des mois
donc on jugera s'il a lancé la solide
dans bond par ailleurs évidemment on va
parler de cette charte de ce projet de
charte lors de cette campagne électorale
et fatima houda pépin a députée
indépendante est allé faire un tour au
parti québécois aujourd'hui on n'a
jamais autant vu fatima houda-pepin
depuis son élection à 94 que lors des
deux dernières semaines
et la visite est en effet le parti
québécois aujourd'hui pour présenter son
projet de loi sur la neutralité de
l'état et semble-t-il selon elle elle a
reçu un accueil relativement chaleureux
et d'ouverture du parti québécois
roddick
j'ai reçu une écoute j'ai reçu un
intérêt par rapport au projet de loi et
je leur ai dit d'entrée de jeu sur la
question des signes religieux on va pas
s'entendre mois voici ma position et je
sais que vous faites du mur à mur je le
sais c'est ça divise la société je leur
ai dit
sébastien on rappelle aux gens que la
position d' adam foote houda-pepin cetc
bouchard taylor donc interdire pour les
juges les policiers les gardiens de
prison et c est leur ami que le parti
libéral du québec se rendre jusque là ce
qui n'a pas été le cas elles se trouvent
un peu entre deux parties entre deux
visions elle pousse un peu plus loin
aussi sur les mariages forcés et les
mutilations génitales ce qu'elle est le
combat qu'ils mènent contre l'intégrisme
religieux ce que la charte des valeurs
ne fait pas voilà par ailleurs
vérificateur général a entendu l'appel
de la première ministre il va déposer
non pas jeudi mais demain ces chiffres
oui ils devaient déposer son rapport sur
l'analyse des chiffres du mois de
novembre dernier c'était la mise à jour
économique devait déposer sa jeudi en
même temps que le budget hors madame
marois a compris que il pouvait y avoir
un conflit d'horaire dans les
informations qu'ils allaient être
transmises au public jeudi elle a
demandé publiquement à monsieur samson
que vous apercevez de changer la date du
dépôt de son rapport il a entendu
à
deux dates pour lui donner toute la
place demain c'est probablement qu'il ne
craint pas beaucoup le rapport du
vérificateur général sur sa mise à jour
et sur l'analyse des chiffres que
monsieur samson a fait